I made a vow to love you faithfully I
swore to keep you safe and I won't
it's just roll your eyes at me you gonna
do about it
I'll pick you up a five I may not be
done by then why do you define me what's
this gray I just want you to be see how
are you good morning wife my husband
I'll pick you up the fire I might not be
done by then I should misbehave more
often we're being followed
how the hell are you Anna this war keep
you safe then I will
[Music]
first long as we both shall live
[Music]
good morning wife
come on a nose man
this is great look out your window no
I'm taking you away for the weekend I
just can't believe this is my life that
I get to live with you
it meant nothing to me before you Anna
Gray's office we wanted to welcome the
new fiction editor
I bought it for us I should have asked
you first
oh my god Christian this is Jim Matteo
the architect this location is perfect
I'm going to build you a fabulous house
please stop speaking of my husband as if
I weren't here Anna you may call me mrs.
grey I'll pick you up the fire I may not
be done by Bank
cuz real
we're being followed
how the hell are you Anna
Jack what you want
so you want to play yes sir
I made a vow to love you faithfully
forsaking all others did you sleep with
her to comfort few when times of need
and to keep you safe first long as we
both shall live
you